the US president a dramatic announcement
I am officially declaring a national
emergency two very big words with more
than 40 dead and the number of infected
growing the president has opened up
funding and cleared states to take
important steps to blunt the spread of
the virus merging every state to set up
emergency operation centers effective
immediately I'm also asking every
hospital in this country to activate its
emergency preparedness plan so that they
can meet the needs of Americans
everywhere the hospitals are very
engaged but the president refused to
accept the crisis is no much greater
because testing wasn't more widely
available no I don't take responsibility
at all because we were given a a set of
circumstances and we were given rules
regulations and specifications from a
different time wasn't meant for this
kind of an event with the kind of
numbers that we're talking about the
Trump administration is planning to
introduce drive-through testing there
will be a website to tell people if they
need the tests and we're to get it
what's missing is when these new
measures will kick in the government's
top expert says he hopes these steps
will shorten the epidemic speaker and
what you've seen now with this order is
that we're going to be able to remove
the constraints so that people at the
state the local level the individual
physician all the way up through the
federal government will have as many
constraints as possible removed for them
to do everything they possibly can so
that we can implement the things that
we've been talking about across the city
on Capitol Hill the House of
Representatives is working on a relief
bill to help people impacted by the
virus it'll provide paid sick leave for
those who've to skip work and provide
free widespread testing the three most
important parts of this bill are testing
testing testing
this legislation facilitates free
coronavirus testing for everyone who
needs a test including the uninsured
President Trump was forced to take
action as public life across America is
being impacted with sports events
canceled schools closed
events postponed it's a remarkable step
from a man who initially claimed
coronavirus was being hyped to
politically damage him and his
reelection efforts